let us bring in the very man that John
Craig was talking about their former
conservative leader sir Ian Duncan Smith
and you're live Syrian outside the
foreign office
um this visit is it going ahead as far
as you know
well I'll be honest with you we now
don't know because it was definitely
going ahead he was coming here they
thought around about the weekend I've
been in touch with ministers since then
demanding that they tell their officials
they're not to meet him I haven't had uh
anything back from in that regard but I
do say that one of them even sent me a
text to say we don't know whether he's
actually coming so this this is turning
into a mess the reality is he should
never have been told he would be welcome
he's coming off his own bat this looks
to me a little bit like sophistry
perhaps organized by the embassy out in
China so that he comes without
officially being invited but then oh
because he's here we ought to see him
and tell him that we don't approve of
him that would be a coup for the Chinese
government right now this man was
sanctioned by the US government as was
Chen kwango who was the architect of the
oppression of the uyghur and the
genocide they are both sanctioned by the
us we haven't sanctioned and either of
them had we sanctioned them they
wouldn't be allowed here so this man now
the new governor who was his chin
kwango's Deputy is coming off his own
bat to the UK I hear that other
governments in Europe are now having
cold feet about this because the inter
parliamentary Alliance on China is
campaigning in all these countries to
say don't let him in and I think they're
maybe therefore I hope a U-turn from the
government but we've not heard anything
of it yet if they allow their officials
to see him that is an official visit
it's no good saying he just happened to
be here so he saw him that would be an
official visit of a man responsible for
a genocide to over a million people now
in labor camps women being forcibly
sterilized children in re-education
camps this alone is an utter disaster
and we should have no truck with it we
don't need to have a word with him to
tell him that if we sanction him and the
architect it sends a bigger more
powerful Global message than having a
quiet cup of tea and lecturing him oh
dear you shouldn't do this that is
pretty pathetic
pragmatism is how the government
describes it getting somebody over here
to tell them what they've done and what
they're accused of
do we honestly think that a man that's
coming here off his own bat it the
foreign office actually says they didn't
invite him so they're now using denial
but while he's here they say they will
get the message across they don't
approve of what he's doing by sitting
down in a private location not in this
building over here but somewhere else to
tell them that they don't approve of
what he's doing it's a much shorter and
simpler way to do this sanction him like
the U.S has sanctioned shenkong go like
the U.S has and others too we sanctioned
four rather lowly officials that was it
people like myself Helena Kennedy and
many others in both their houses of
Parliament we have been sanctioned by
the Chinese government so they've sent a
message to us you're not welcome in
China okay that's their message we
haven't done the except raise a human
rights issue these two are responsible
for the human rights problem that is to
say the genocide of the uyghur I think
the only thing to do when you want to
send a message is do it both feet first
in other words you are sanctioned you
are no longer welcome in the United
Kingdom or any of its attending
territories that is the end of it that
sends a much more powerful message to
China that we do not in any way condone
or even accept that what China's doing
has any legitimacy and if they don't
stop it we will carry out further
sanctions why don't you think he's been
sanctioned here
I think there's a fear that somehow the
treasury is quietly and others saying oh
don't do this we might upset the
business in China which is important so
we mustn't go too far the trouble is
it's worth doing a little bit and not
the whole thing because what you end up
is looking weak and China then kicks you
around China understands strength and
the reality for us is the strongest
thing we can do is to tell them this has
to stop by joining with the Americans
and others of our allies and all
together making sure we sanction those
who are guilty of this massive terrible
murderous abuse and we should do it
today that would be the best thing even
if he hasn't landed yet he's sanctioned
he can't get off the aircraft you better
catch another one back to Beijing